live local now very emotional day in
court as a teen who brutally attacked an
El Dorado High School teacher was
sentenced to a minimum of 16 years
behind bars that attack happened last
April but the trauma from the attack
something the victim says she may never
recover from 8 news now reporter
Victoria Saha in court as the defense
and prosecutors delivered their closing
arguments
today remembers him saying is why won't
you just die those are the words the
prosecutors say the teacher Sade kept
remembering as she was attacked she was
opening her doors
students because she trusted them it was
after school April 7 2022 when then 16
year old Jonathan Martinez Garcia went
to his teacher's room to discuss grades
prosecutors say Martinez Garcia waited
for Sade's back to be turned when he
started strangling her raping her
cutting her wrists and then trapping her
under heavy bookshelves I'm sorry
and I remember what I've done I will
tell myself I've known I was to blame by
myself but his attorney Tyler Gaston did
have something to blame the meds
Martinez Garcia was on he just has no
history of anything but being a perfect
loving kid Gaston says Martinez Garcia
was having hallucinations and night
terrors after taking a drug called Monty
Lucas to help with his asthma this is
the real Jonathan when not on
Montelukast Jonathan did something bad
to somebody else so us as a society
should do something bad to him that's
not Justice the courtroom packed with
people who spoke on Sade's behalf and
then we heard from Sade herself I would
wake up in a new spot in position each
time he'd beat my body so badly that I
came along and fight that only makes
sense that he too should be in prison
for as long as possible since it
happened there hasn't been a single
night where I haven't dreamed about the
attack judge Kathleen Delaney says an
attack on Educators is unacceptable it
is the most heinous type of crime that
there could be